filomena sigue dejando estragos en
españa' con el avance del temporal se
espera el cese de las nevadas y la
llegada de una ola de frío con
temperaturas que alcanzarían los menos
10 grados centígrados tras una reunión
de emergencia el gobierno informó que se
cumplieran con los plazos de vacunación
contra el cubit 19 como estaba previsto
el aeropuerto que podemos decir que
podría ser un poco más preocupante es el
de barajas pero está previsto que en la
madrugada de hoy en la madrugada próxima
del lunes pueda aterrizar un vuelo con
las dosis de esta semana y que podamos y
tomamos todas las medidas precisas para
evidentemente su distribución posterior
en los centros sanitarios de las
comunidades correspondientes el
aeropuerto de barajas- cerrado desde el
8 de enero reabrirá gradualmente y se
prevé que lleguen varios vuelos con
alimentos y vacunas a las zonas que han
quedado aisladas por el temporal ahora
el gobierno advierte de la importancia
de seguir con las indicaciones para
enfrentar la ola de frío
no debemos bajar la guardia mantengamos
la alerta y previsión ante la llegada
mañana de la ola de frío sigamos las
indicaciones de los servicios de
emergencia y evitemos los
desplazamientos por nuestra seguridad y
para garantizar los servicios esenciales
y el abastecimiento la tormenta deja
hasta el momento 4 personas muertas así
como el desabastecimiento de alimentos
en supermercados y una fuerte reducción
de la movilidad